Ah ah ah It's a
refrigerated research club. Please wait a moment
. Before the announcement, I have doubts about the activities of the research club or its behavior.
According to one source, the video prefecture broke through the iron wall with a tackle.  It's
like breaking the iron pipe plan. This is all
a heart medical act performed on the material provided by the school
. Isn't this a big problem?
There is a complaint from the Ani Lab.
During the uncut screening, the video prefecture suffered damage by catching a large catch,
and at that time, a person outside the school entered, or
do you think that this is water? No problem.  I think
that
there is a story that can support wild tanuki. It's a problem. Gon giant
grounds.
What should I do with such a school?
The reservation is suspended so that it will not be
lost. The reason why the corn boo room was broken is because it is aging. The
school also accepts responsibility.
This is a case where the responsibility of the bill on the side is questioned. This is all a problem on the public side. Do
you talk about misconduct? Teacher
Please do not talk about school misconduct.
Does the society enforce such emotional authority?